right so here's your diagram
three squares and here's the question
we're trying to answer if you've got
these three angles
okay what's the sum of all the angles
equal to now
most of you either by measurement or by
a trig and
kind of using your calculator to help
you most of you realize that some of
them is equal to
90 degrees 90 degrees which just before
you go any further
is the classic example of like
why why should that be 90 degrees like
90 degrees is you know
it's it's such an important angle we
call it the right angle okay
but why should these three when you add
them together
why should they give you that result
that's a bit strange
to show you why it is 90 degrees you
don't need tree
um you hardly even need like congruence
really in fact
i reckon a primary school student knows
enough
about geometry to solve this question
yes that is exactly what i'm doing okay
so now let me show you okay
um i did say that constructions would be
helpful
okay so i'm going to show you one way of
approaching this
and there are other ways but i think
this is the simplest kind
here's the first kick construction see
your three squares right your three
squares there
you need to draw three more squares but
above
directly above okay so i'm going to draw
them a bit necessarily like so
it's not too bad so i put three squares
on top of it
and now i need to just draw two more
lines and my constructions will be over
and then i just need to examine the
angles okay so my two more lines
are i'm going to form a triangle by
going up
there it's one and by going down
there okay so that's it that's all the
constructions i'm going to need
okay now how are we going to show this
because
it turns out to be such a neat number
okay this is actually very helpful to
you because if it was some other awkward
number like say 75 degrees
it's like where is 75 degrees in this
diagram you wouldn't have to appeal to
something like trig or other weird stuff
to
answer this but because it's 90 degrees
there are 90 degree angles
everywhere in this diagram right so if i
can just
find where alpha beta and gamma are
together and show that they coincide in
a right angle
i'm done okay and i kind of was trying
to give you a bit of a hit in that
direction by
telling you what this angle up here was
but um evidently we didn't quite get
there
so i'm going to show you how to approach
this um everyone knows that alpha
the size of alpha is easy to determine
it's 45 degrees
can you tell me why is it 45 degrees
good so they're all squares so you've
got a right angle here
also because they're squares you've got
two equal signs
right so you've got an isosceles
triangle in the corner here so if that's
90
these two must be 45 each that's fine
but better in gamma if you go ahead and
you do your tree
right for instance if i say
10 beer right now
you haven't got any lengths here you
have no legs here
right the whole point of this what's
cool about it is it doesn't matter what
the lengths are
what you draw will still be similar to
mine all the angles will be the same
okay
so you don't know how long this is in
relation to this
in terms of actual lengths but tan
and sine and cos all it is
is a ratio it's just a ratio it's
opposite over adjacent right which is
how much bigger is this side than this
side this is the right angle
triangle i'm in yeah okay so the
opposite side is
one square side length and the adjacent
side down here is
two square side legs so opposite over
adjacent should be
one over two yes now when you
when you take that you say well okay
therefore beta equals tan
inverse of a half and you go ahead and
you crunch that number it's not neat
it's something messy what is it it's
like 20 something degrees i think
um whatever it is is not exact okay
so these two are obviously not going to
be as easy
as alpha okay
all right so how am i going to rearrange
things
well here's my question to you where
else can you see
angles like alpha and beta let's start
with beta b is actually easier remember
i
introduced all these new constructions
right in the new constructions i made
where else can you see peter
any takers territory
uh describe describe at the top
here is this one okay yeah
all right so so this is beta this is
beta okay can you see why it's bigger
what what would you what would be the
simplest way to say that must be beta
as well
think simple exterior i would say
symmetry i would say symmetry because
look when i went from here up to the top
to say three squares right look at this
line
clearly it's a reflection of this line
which i used to form beta
is that okay thumbs up so b here that
means i beat it there
i can see another beat up based on the
lines i've constructed where else yeah
um it's in the top light square just to
the right of the
diagonal here yeah okay all right
i've got beater in there as well okay
hmm now there's one more place i can see
vita actually sorry i take that back
there's lots
uh why is that video yeah good question
why is that peter
so how did i how did i make bigger in
the first place i had two squares
and i joined that diagonal so i had a
rectangle that was
two squares beside each other well this
is the same set up
two squares they're all squares yeah so
if you look at it from
this angle going up to the top here it's
just like this angle
going up to the top there so it's still
two squares beside each other
and it's that same 20 something degree
angle there
all right
okay all right i'm gonna pause for a
second i think this is what you're
talking about
yeah okay now vina is here but i'm
actually gonna not worry about putting
veda there
you'll see why in a second there's one
more important place peter is
and that's down here okay can you see
why it's there
i mean it's there for the same reason
this is there and you've got alternate
angles anyway
so i got beaten there now look carefully
what am i trying to prove
this is what i'm after right right
oh so therefore i want all of these
angles to be together somewhere and form
a right angle
like where bottom right hand corner
right so if i can show
that this angle here is alpha it's 45
degrees i'm done
i'm already there okay can you see where
i'm going to do it
well have a look we started the first
places you saw beta we're here and here
right here and here we'll have a look at
this one right if beta is here
tell me what's this angle equal to
this is this whole thing is a right
angle because it's square right
so these two angles must add up to 90
degrees so this here is 90
minus beta right there see that
but now if you shift over a little bit
if this is 90 minus beta
and this is beta then then this angle
off at a slant that's also a right angle
isn't it
are the wheels turning i see it all
right
hold on not everyone saw it so i have it
right over there
stay with me you can also see
because of the same symmetry to this
right see this line up here
it's from the corner of this rectangle
up to there well this side
must be the same as this line here it's
formed in exactly the same way it's from
the corner of one
to the opposite of the same size
rectangle
two squares next to each other so that
means this whole thing is an isosceles
triangle
you've got 90 up there that means this
is alpha
and this is alpha because they're both